hi I'm Elle pursue gossipy and I play
Valentina hi I'm Emily Tosta and I play
Lucia I'm Nico Guardado and I played
Bethel hi I'm Brandon Laura Quinta and I
play Emilio and we're here with BuzzFeed
to play which original party 5 character
are you quiz
how would your friends describe you
charming adventurous I think I'm gonna
pick out a venturous for me because my
friends are always saying that they're
getting motivated
I don't know I'm always motivated to do
anything I think I'm gonna piggyback off
of Val yeah let's find motivation yeah
I'm gonna have to go without going
because I feel oh yeah take a school
subject you've got a math history
English science art and PE PE
yeah all the way of course of course
your husband how are you bad a P English
science or math because math is fun once
you get it she said that that's fun once
you did I'm gonna do history because I
feel like I'm okay okay next one
choose a 90's movie okay we got clueless
Titanic your essay part 10 Things I Hate
About You never seen that scream oh yeah
scream Neve Campbell huh to the lines
being
yeah yeah mine is Titanic Jurassic Park
or scream I'm have to go live I'm gonna
pick Titanic it's just a classic oh my
go wrong pick a place to visit and San
Francisco the Golden Gate Bridge
Alcatraz Island fishermen harm the
Painted Ladies Twin Peaks and Walt
Disney Family museum I'm I have to go
with the Golden Gate Bridge actually
because I just did stop me being
different just to talk to me it says me
I think I'm gonna go with Alcatraz
Island I probably pronounce that room
because my accent came out but I'm just
gonna go with it choose something to
order at Salinger's I have to go a pasta
where we go we got the Pierson family
Gilmore family Brady family banks family
buyers family rose family the banks
family yeah okay I'm going with Gilmore
Girls I'm gonna go with the buyers from
the stranger things let's do it
Christon bed now why why did you get
them okay okay okay you want to read
half and then already have no you're
better at reading okay your personality
matches charlie you're adventurous
independent and a leader
Oh like Charlie or someone who wants to
explore the world around you however
your family's always a top priority for
you while you struggle with having a lot
of responsibility you're always there
when someone needs it says your
personality matches Bailey you're
charismatic strong and rebellious like
Bailey here's someone who loves to
surround yourself with a lot of friends
you're the life of the party and you
just love to have a good time even if
that means forgetting some of your
responsibilities so you personally match
with Kirsten you're thoughtful
affectionate and kind you're a caregiver
who is constantly striving to make the
people around you feel welcome you to
your compassionate nature you find it
easy to make friends with everyone thank
you so much for joining us here on
BuzzFeed
please watch party of five on freeform
[Music]